Hey Youtubers, it’s Charlie and Walking
Dead finally revealed Terminus and gave us
a big reunion we’d been hoping for.
There are still a lot of huge questions, mostly
who is going to die in the finale, but we
did get to see almost all the survivors.
So what I’m going to do is my top 5 moments
and then talk about some of the biggest questions
for the finale with some possible solutions.
Quick shout out for this week’s giveaway.
If you’re finding me for the first time,
each week in these Walking Dead reviews I
pick one random subscriber to give an amazon
giftcard to.
All you have to do is be a subscriber and
leave a comment.
It’s just my way of saying thank you to
all you guys for being awesome.
I’ll announce who the winner is in my Walking
Dead Q&A tomorrow.
So let’s talk some Terminus.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Here we go.
Number 5 - Outdoor Cat Daryl.
Joe seemed unusually cogent while he explained
his brave new world to Daryl.
I loved that he just drops cat facts.
Daryl never did answer as to whether or not
he was a cat person.
The speech was just Joe telling Daryl that
he was an outdoor cat just like them.
Like their band of marauders is the alternative
to the more domesticated survivors.
Who I guess we can call indoor cats.
Unless you count Michonne.
No amount of play time with Carl and candy
sharing will make her an indoor cat.
The writers are just teasing that Daryl might
seriously decide to split with the survivors
and start running with Joe’s group.
Which we totally do not want.
Joe himself after all these wolfpack justice
moments seems legit.
He’s not a cannibal, so I think we can assume
that if there are going to be Hunters, they’ll
be the people who live at Terminus.
The real thing to worry about with their group
though, is how is Daryl going to react when
Joe’s group finds Rick.
That last moment before the candy wrapper
let us know that Tony, that dude who got strangled
for the bed.
Totally saw him.
We can call this one of the giant red flags
to look of for in the finale.
Number 4 - Glenn Finds Maggie’s Sign
This was such a fun high point to start the
episode off on.
You could almost tell what it was from the
look on his face before they revealed the
map.
And as expected he takes off like a crazy
person to catch up to her.
His commitment to people is borderline crazy
and it will definitely get him killed someday,
but since this happened so early in the episode
I wasn’t expecting things to get awful until
they approached the Tunnel of Death.
There’s just something so awesome about
the imagery of the mouth of that tunnel.
LIke they were stepping into a Walker’s
open mouth.
We’ve gotten to know Glenn so well over
the years, that I don’t think this could
have gone down any other way.
Until he was reunited with Maggie he was in
Robo-Glenn mode.
Which also kind of makes him a dick in that
he’s forcing Tara to injure herself more
by following.
I think if anyone has the chance to martyr
themselves this season, it will be Tara.
She just wants to punish herself so bad.
I’ll talk about this more later, but if
she really wanted to punish herself, she’d
get involved with another girlfriend.
Because being in a loving relationship on
the show is a recipe for disaster.
Number 3 - Glenn and Tara in The Tunnel of
Death
I liked how as they moved deeper into the
tunnel, they moved deeper into their awful
memories.
Glenn in his time right after he was separated
from his family.
And Tara during the prison battle.
Did you notice how she always calls the Governor
“Brian”, it’s just because she never
knew him as the Governor.
It’s funny, just because we’ve known him
as this other persona for so long.
Them running into the Walkers just implies
that they chose the wrong path.
Supposedly there was a huge tribute Walker
in the episode and I think it was a Ray Harryhausen
tribute with this stop motion looking walker
was saw from behind.
Let me know if you think it was a different
Walker.
I kept looking at all the close-up shots of
them to see if I recognized them from something
else.
Number 2 - Maggie and Glenn’s machine gun
reunion.
How appropriate that it happened to the sweet
music of gunfire.
They’re both sufficiently crazy, so you
couldn’t get them back together in anything
less than a shitballs crazy situation.
In this moment I also include Tara trying
to get Glenn to bail on her and save himself.
It felt kind of hollow, because Glenn has
proven himself to be the most stubborn person
on the show, next to Maggie.
I don’t think he would ever give up on someone.
Maybe if he was forced to choose between Maggie
and someone else.
That would be an interesting situation.
After their reunion I renamed the Tunnel of
Death to the tunnel of Love.
Earlier when I said loving relationships are
recipies for disaster, what I meant was that
almost all the sex pairs had someone die,
for instance, Lori and Lilly both slept with
the Governor and they’re dead.
All of Beth’s boyfriends are dead.
Lori slept with Shane and she’s dead.
This mean that Abraham, Rosita, Sasha, Bob,
Glenn and Maggie are all on my most likely
to die list.
Maggie really is still my number one pick.
Just in a reversal of canon.
and my Number 1 moment - Glenn, Maggie and
Abraham’s group reaches Terminus.
And it looks like it’s full of indoor cats.
It really does look like a more flowery version
of the prison.
But there’s a mystery Grill that makes me
think that in the finale they’re going to
be revealed as the Hunters and it will be
people meat on that grill.
We should call it right now, regardless of
what’s happening there, Terminus is a venus
fly trap.
That will be shutting it’s jaws on a few
people in the finale.
The big questions now are, who are these people
at Terminus, are they the Hunters?
What is the lie of Terminus.
I’m a convinced there will be a huge reveal.
Hunters or Not, we still haven’t met that
new character Gareth.
The other big questions are what happened
to Beth and what will Joe’s group do to
Rick when they catch up to him?
There’s also that new person Mary we just
met, that’s Denise Crosby.
And she doesn’t exactly conform to anyone
specifically in the comic books.
She could be the female Hunter, but in order
for that to work out, the show would have
to change a bunch of stuff.
I just feel like that Grill she was standing
in front of is so ominous.
It looks a lot like the scene in the comics
with the Hunters home base.
Even though that was a very small group of
people.
As for Beth, I don’t have any evidence to
support it, but part of me feels like she’s
still alive at Terminus somewhere.
I feel like we’re going to end up in a situation
at Terminus, where Joe’s group will make
a move on Rick and everyone will be too busy
to notice the evil Terminus people trying
to kill everyone.
Now it’s your turn though.
Let me know what your favorite moment was
and what your biggest question is before the
finale?
Don’t forget, there’s still the wild card
of Carol and Tyreese, they’re two very badass
people.
I feel like even though they have Judith with
them, they’re not any less formidable.
Can’t you just see them hiking Judith back
and forth to one another like a football while
they kill walkers.
What I’m really hoping to see is a darkest
moment situation where Tyreese comes barreling
through a wall like the Hulk and just smashes
Joe and any potential Terminus Hunter characters.
Like I said, I’m posting that Q&A tomorrow
with the giveaway winner announcement.
Click here for that video.
I’ll update the annotation as soon as I
post it.
And click here for last week’s mega WTF
episode.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
Terminus High Fives!